you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on leeches
org and I just got paired up playing a
five-o game so no living off of the
increment now that's pretty rare b6 I
like going for this setup and reply to
it a quick ideal center and then
reinforce e4 that's really Queenie -
it's pretty quick but I think it's fine
to do that and c5 will go c3
let's get Knight f3 and c5 c3 you have
to be a little bit cautious of this I
may end up doing C 3 and a 3 want to
maintain this structure so let's do this
knight c6 83 ok that's a bit surprising
alright let's give this night at kick
challenge it if it jumps into e4 with
the night here hmm
let's get Castle they might try Queen c8
mmm ok so they're preparing to exchange
light square bishop so I'm looking to
sink my Knight into there mmm yeah let's
do this right here and then Knight a 3
into B 5
actually maybe Bishop g5 first hmm
let's try this let's see if they give me
their dark square bishop then I can
maybe look forward to getting my Knight
to d6 otherwise they have to move their
queen to probably a bit of an awkward
square don't really want to go to the C
file I'm expecting captures and I'll be
giving up one of these two squares
regardless of how I recapture on d4 hmm
not sure which one's better to give up
okay so they are giving up the dark
square bishop so maybe if the C file
does open up I could be a pest in that I
control c8 I maintain pressure on this
night okay so they're just ruling that
out all together maybe I still go there
hmm
okay well their nights are pretty
restricted playing I'm playing with the
space advantage I think I'm going to do
a knight reposition a knight on d3 I
think could be quite good so this pond
does a good job in restricting this
Knight and a lot of the black pawns do a
good job in restricting the knight on c7
both are and they well this one's in the
defense and defensive posture watching
out for Knight b5 let's develop my
knight and I can look forward to this
plan f4 f5 let's see what black does
disturb some trouble if they push here
okay or not hmm I play f4 f4 f5 on f4
they play f5 hmm or do I take and try
play against this Knight hmm
okay let's see I'm not sure what else to
consider here pushing at some point I
don't know about that hmm
I'm gonna maintain life on here I'm
going to look to restrict their nights I
don't know if my nights are any better
be perfectly honest in its it's tough to
see how to move forward after f5 okay
hmm I don't know if I like my night
position anymore
maybe he wants to actually go to f3 now
all right let's try this a lot of time
is being invested here but it's a pretty
locked position so are they gonna try
something bold like captures Queen to b4
hmm and I know about that let's get my
knight here actually on takes I could
take with my knight I could consider
taking like that
cuz I would have pressure here there'd
be a little bit of a trade-off I could
get this square ever they get on e4 like
before maybe pawn takes yeah I'm going
to do this right now actually and I'm
not quite sure how to recapture I was
thinking pawn just to restrict this
Knight can't go to here and if he goes
here you can't go to these two hmm I may
end up losing that pond though if they
push and then go here and take what the
Queen seems pretty active I guess I'm
slow improving was like h3 just has a
flight square
maybe c4 and B 3 and C 4 is an idea sure
maybe look to open this position up huh
as it stands right now I'm threatening
b6 so they have to tend to that and mine
I could strike at a 6 by g5
so I'd like to open this up and then
maybe throw in a quick strike here and
restrict one of their minor pieces to
defending the square so maybe B 3 and C
4 is good way forward
hmmm let's shoot for that
I may take with my night I'm paying the
ruling that out see for my queens short
on squares but she can't be trapped also
my queen could also attack East six so
I'm seeing him I'm better because of my
night position primarily I have a little
bit of a space advantage I'm seeing this
as a target hmm pawn takes I'm going to
take like this I have some lateral
pressure ensuing moves one of my rooks
or maybe both rooks to the C and D file
I'd like to get this move in h3 they're
down on time no increment here I might
close to just winning upon here tonight
c6 I could always take here and my queen
is then threatening on b6 so could I
already pre move this D take C Queen
take C probably okay hmm maybe I'd take
here or take this square first take the
Queen hmm no I don't want to invite
their Knight forward let's take care I
might end up with BB pawns yes okay but
let's see let me put pressure on the c5
pawn like this I could give the night at
kick a timely kick with e6 they're at
about a minute
who I have two super dangerous pawns now
connected passers so let me take care
first and I wonder about doing this
first just to kill the night huh I could
definitely think about doing that hmm
I'm gonna keep pushing though like this
I want to keep a nice pawn chain I may
drop him though not really actually
let's improve my night position no if
Rick c5 I have 96 with the fork okay
they ran right into that you know so my
only concern is that they end up with
those two
is there something better let's take
care first and okay let's take here and
I'm going to pin the knight and also be
in a position to get behind that pawn
hmm let's go here
all right there knight on e6 is pretty
strong let's defend that for they might
try g5 let's get behind him as soon as
possible and activate my other rook
first and then I'm threatening this
actually I pressure on the night it
might get made it
now I'm getting their name my not yeah
this should be good now I'll be getting
their Knight and get behind that these
pastors they just resigned who I'm not
sure what to make of let me go into the
analysis board let me not put on the
local evaluation just yet
tough I mean this is what black is
signing up for really when when you go
with this system light will be able to
get this nice ideal pond center black
could make it flinch like they did
eventually with the d5 so it shifts
somewhat it goes from having it an ideal
pond center to a space advantage you
know it's pawn on e5 the 9s to find a
new home I don't know I'm not quite sure
what to make of this position you know
the a4 move the positive with that is
that it controls this be 5 square which
is a hole on the black end but hmm you
know the drawback is that when this
capture occurs if I take like this mmm I
guess the knight will be able to go to
c5 regardless I'm just I'm just
wondering if I'm making an unnecessary
weakness by playing a for thinking about
jumping here I guess there's a little
bit of a give and take
yeah actually no matter what I'm Tate
okay here here's this here's the
situation if I if I still keep my pawn
on a 2 then I still always can watch
over b4 for example if I just make a
passing move if they're capturing like
this I could capture like this and keep
the knight out of c5 and I don't have
any worries of the knight jumping into
EU 4 he's he's boxed out nicely c5 is
under control and trying to make use of
b4 I still can rule that out with a 3 so
while I'm trying to eventually anchor a
piece into this weakened square on b5
there's some drawback as well and that
b4 is maybe a squared that black can
exploit so hmm dark squared bishop tsar
off the knights kind of
hmm what's the make of it there
definitely well I have the better
night's
I'd much rather my nights then and
there's here I have this space advantage
I'm trying to figure out what would be a
good pawn break I don't know if this is
really helping me
yeah like capturing like this is not
helping me I just gave up a perfectly
good nice strong central pawn and now
they have something to bite at so it's
important that I just leave this sitting
so the only other pawn break that I'm
looking into is c4 but I don't believe
that this is helpful because this Knight
can now make use of d5 at some point you
know castles and if I'm ever taking well
what a wonderful square this is so I
kind of had a plate I kind of had to
play this one slow I think that's why I
went with this little repositioning move
91 castles 93 let's actually have a look
at what the graph is saying it is in
favor
it didn't really drop you know right
here actually list right around this
point let me put on the computer does it
is it in favor of f4 here it wants to
take okay there's nothing wrong with
that for either what was my concern with
this I didn't get to voice it but it was
just this idea of peace play yeah the
rooks finally having some nice play I
don't know about nice play but some play
some activity now in the F file I
realized that this is a backward pond
but I don't know how to really get at it
it's it's defended by the super
defensive piece on c7 he's watching out
for Knight b5 and now he would have the
role of watching over the backward east
six pawn
okay so this is an idea B 3 and C 4
uh-huh B 3 and C 4 so that on takes I
can recapture and maintain my control
over this square which still kills the
night at C seven doesn't allow him to
jump into play like I had pointed out
earlier if it's C four move is played
and some capture the night gets to post
up on d5 but prepping it first with B
three and only then C 4 is a different
story so this is a way forward is the
short story if I did want to go with
this capture okay now it also points out
F four so I guess I have my pick no
serious drawback with taking or just
maintaining my opponent e5 yeah okay so
I went with f4 five and now it looks to
go forward with b3 yeah okay I went with
the reposition here so I guess the most
efficient way is to go with B 3 and C 4
okay I could see that now it's only
giving us a half pound advantage going
with C far right away yeah okay well
it's not not working because of d4 so a
little more prep work is needed here I
don't know about g 6h 6 seems more
human-like I don't like these g6 moves
that it's suggesting I like having this
is a better home for the King it's a
it's a nice pocket for the King pushing
that Jeep on you know much more
vulnerable to being cut off one day by a
major piece and the King maybe won't be
able to move forward mm-hm
but ok we had f5 and I repositioned my
knight to f3 a lot of repositioning here
huh I went into V 4 takes Queen takes
and yeah this was my fear of this move
and then this pawn being hunted down you
know this is kind of awkward
I guess that's to meet some pressure on
before with defense yeah defense by my
most valuable piece so I didn't like
that idea of taking at the pond I Somme
has overextended if it wasn't if I did
not have some fear of this pond being a
liability on b5 I would recapture
because I like this fact that it kills
the night and if he goes here that this
pond kills the night from d7i there may
be situations in the game where you
could devise a plan around this about
devise a plan around restricting a
single piece a night he's he's dead on
b8 and even when he plays here he's also
dead so it's it's difficult to see how
the night would be able to make progress
if I'm able to maintain upon on b5 and
d4 there's other factors of course play
along the C file a timely opening up of
the file and black maybe grabbing some
initiative or you know some play along
the the C file due to their quick
control over it but yeah some plan might
be tied in with restricting in the night
so and you know I took with the Queen I
didn't want to lose a beep on and now c4
I prepped it first with b3 I guess that
wasn't needed I could go straight in for
c4 okay I went with the b3 now c4 and I
guess when it opens up this is when I
just become better takes pawn takes yeah
and this Knight still is underdeveloped
it's it's pointing out this move and
this is this is a way to completely kill
the night he has these two and I only
need one more controlled rook here and
these pawns are just too strong now 94
you know I don't think anything was
really missed here huh starts to be a
growing growing advantage
it doesn't like that move wants to
insert a check first mm-hmm something
was lost there I guess this is one of
the last points really this one rook
here hmm
okay I'm King here now this so the
knight can't make use of that square
okay yeah this is certainly inconvenient
for the King isn't it hmm
if he goes here well he's going away
from his desired area which is towards
the center and now I get to do this
stuff and really play against this
Knight he's the one who huh it's the one
who probably was the cause for the loss
I think he had a tough time getting
active hmm so I could have I mean I was
looking at restricting the knight
earlier with pawns but even with piece
play we could look to restrict this
Knight so rook here Knight d6 yeah I was
a little bit awkward now for me to
disrupt the King position so I just
defended you know I thought they might
strike here right away and we went with
a five and I just got behind right away
look there rook c6 and then that's going
to do it I guess the last question I
have is what would I have done if they
did play after g3 suppose they did play
g5 I still just enter you know in pawn
takes takes Knight takes ooh yeah
they're getting cut off huh
mate threats and stuff yikes yeah
everything is just following though just
to defend me they have to drop both of
their there are connected passed pawns
and I just have a really active rooks
there so yes and I can't go too far away
he has to defend that up hibbott Square
and c7
okay well really not sure what more to
add with this one that's basically you
know that's pretty much it because these
works just got active and wherever he
goes here I'm getting the knight next
okay um
fairly happy with how things went and
this one feel free especially with the
clock situation with no increment for
this one but anyhow feel free to leave
any feedback in the comments section
below to this video as usual and I hope
you got something out of it that's all
for now take care bye